din jaren the mandalorian's titular
bounty hunter has
had a wild ride since he crossed paths
with the child
also known as grogu luckily jiren has a
variety of weapons to protect himself
and his little companion let's take a
look at some of jaron's gear but be
warned
spoilers are ahead mandalorian helmets
have long been associated with the star
wars creed and jaron's helmet is
no exception just like with any other
mandalorian helmet jaren's features a
t-shaped visor and
entirely conceals his face also jaren's
tribe follows the way of the mandalore a
religion where members are not allowed
to remove their helmets in public
if they do they can never put them back
on again why you ask
this is the way this is the way
jarn has been seen without his helmet in
public only twice so far
in chapter 8 redemption because he was
badly injured and needed a droid to tend
to his wounds and in chapter 15 the
believer
to bypass an imperial security scan
mando's helmet
also comes with a variety of features
such as tracking heat signatures
long range audio and detecting recent
footsteps left on the ground
these perks are especially useful when
jarrah needs to locate nearby
individuals whether they be enemies or
those in need of assistance
jaren's mandalorian armor not only looks
cool but it is also
extremely durable it's made out of a
powerful metal alloy called descar
which is known to withstand blaster fire
and even the might of a lightsaber
since jaren's armor is badly damaged in
the show's sophomore episode he brings a
large payment of besgar
to his tribe's armor who uses it to
craft a new quiros
instead of having a red and gray color
scheme in the vein of his previous armor
this shiny new armor is metallic silver
just like his helmet
in redemption the armorer announces the
formation of jaron's clan
clan mudhorn which is made up of himself
and the child
to coincide with this formation the
armorer inscribes the skull of the
mudhorn on his right pauldron as his
signet
jarrin's dual flamethrowers have come in
handy time and time again
for instance in chapter 3 the sin jarn
uses a flamethrower to torch an
attacking stormtrooper
he's even been known to bring the heat
when words fail him you understand this
like any weapon in star wars however
flamethrowers have their limits after
jaren is surrounded by bounty hunters
who all want the child he uses a
flamethrower to drive them away but
it runs out of juice when he needs it
most while boba fett
first used a variation of this weapon in
the animated segment from the infamous
star
wars holiday special the ambient phase
pulse blaster in the mandalorian seems
to be much more powerful
throughout the course of the series
jaren uses this sniper rifle to either
incapacitate or disintegrate anyone who
stands in his path
these enemies can be big as a transocean
or as small as a jawa
both of whom were killed in the same
episode jaren also uses the blaster to
tase
a wide variety of intergalactic enemies
and creatures such as stormtroopers and
even a crate dragon when jaren returns
to the mandalorian hideout with his best
car payment the armorer uses the excess
material to build him
a special weapon whistling birds these
small guided munitions are placed in his
left vambrace
when deployed the projectiles fly
through the air while making a whistling
sound before striking their targets and
detonating a small explosive
the armorer tells jaren that these
projectiles are rare
so he saves them for desperate moments
star wars fans have often associated jet
packs with mandalorian culture yet
jaren didn't receive his own until the
final episode of season 1.
in redemption the armorer asks mando if
he has ever
trained in the rising phoenix to which
he promptly responds that he did when he
was a boy
the armorer then gives mando a jet pack
and sends him on his way to reunite the
child with its own kind
the jet pack comes in handy later in the
episode when jaren uses it to attack a
thai fighter that's piloted by moth
gideon
jaron also uses the jetpack in the
subsequent episode when he flies out of
the belly of an angry crate dragon
however despite all of its advantages in
warfare the best part about the jetpack
is watching the child's ears flop around
when mando takes him for a ride
flash charges aren't exactly commonplace
in the star wars universe but for jaren
they are especially useful
in chapter 5 the gunslinger this episode
sees mando working with aspiring bounty
hunter toro calacan to capture a wanted
assassin named fenik shand
they soon discover that shand is using a
far away ridge as a makeshift sniper
nest
after nightfall jaron and kalakan use
flash charges to blind shan so they can
apprehend her
before long calacan decides to betray
mando jaren blinds kalikan with a flash
charge and takes him
out it's not a big loss for the galaxy
though in fact
mato could probably sum up kalikan in
two words
womp rat jaron's whip cord has helped
him get out of many deadly situations
in chapter 6 the prisoner for example
jaren takes on several new republic
security droids
throughout the fight mando uses the
grappling hook to behead one droid and
uses it again to bring another one
closer to a droid that's being
incinerated
jaren later finds himself locked in a
jail cell luckily he escapes after he
uses his whip cord to tether a security
droid near his cell door
he then rips off one of its arms which
he uses to open the lock
grenades are probably one of the most
important weapons for jarrin
in fact we've seen him reach for them in
wildly different circumstances
one instance where they were especially
useful happens in chapter 11 the heiress
when jaren bocaton crees and two other
mandalorians infiltrate an imperial
cruiser transporting valuable weapons
after flying to the ship the four
warriors try to take the ship's bridge
but end up encountering a squad of
stormtroopers armed with heavy repeating
blasters all while the captain is
attempting to crash the ship at the
behest of moff gideon
jaren quickly devises a plan to get
himself and the others to the bridge
he asks the three mandalorians to cover
him as he charges toward the remaining
stormtroopers
after getting close enough jaren throws
two grenades at the enemies blowing them
up and creating a path to victory
when speaking of self-preservation a
wise man once said
religions and ancient weapons are no
match for a good blaster at your side
even though jaren knows next to nothing
about the so-called hokey religion
he almost always has a blaster at his
side as he demonstrates many times
throughout the show
jaren is very proficient with his
blaster pistol in fact the initial fight
scene that kicks off the entire series
features mando using his pistol to shoot
the control panel of a door which then
slices a quarren trawler in half
and that's just the first of many
memorable scenes of jaren relying on his
pistol to save the day
and the child check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
mandalorian are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you